(clapping)
- So what did you wanna be
when you were a little kid?
- Oh. (laughs)
I wanted to be alive and--
(laughs)
Not in jail.
I grew up not under great circumstances.
I grew up in the hood.
I was surrounded by a lot
of violence, a lot of crime.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was definitely a
product of my environment.
- Yeah.
- I kind of snapped out
of it when I was older,
when I realized it was
just kind of a dead road.
My mum helped me.
She sent me to live with my dad when I was
I think about 12, 13 when
I was bigger than her
and getting in tons of trouble.
- Yeah.
- So I really didn't honestly
know what I wanted to do
with my life, like for the rest of my life
till I was about 30 years old.
And that's when I knew
that I wanted to be,
I wanted to entertain people.
- That's so cool.
And so cool to say and own
because a lot of people
give up on their dreams
'cause they think they've
aged out of whatever bracket
society tells you you're
supposed to be in.
And that's cool, like at 30 you were like,
I wanna do this.
- Yeah.
- My life started at 30.
I wasted my twenties.
I bounced at night clubs
from the time I was 17
till I was 30.
- Wow!
- Yeah, that's what I did.
- Right on.
And you're all gooshy, like
wishy little teddy bear.
- I'm pretty gooshy.
- And so great.
Your mum is probably like wait, what?
From like your childhood.
- She was.
Well even when I went into
professional wrestling,
because I was such an introverted kid,
she just like, that's you?
Speaking in front of thousands of people?
I can't believe it.
But my mum is actually my
biggest fan like by far.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah.